.
GREAT ADVICE.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT WITH THE ONES
YOU LOVE.
CAN'T GO WRONG.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS ARE SPIKING
THE FOOTBALL BECAUSE INFLATION
IS DOWN A WHOPPING 7.1%.
CONGRATULATIONS, JOEY.
INFLATION IS NOW DOWN FROM A
42-YEAR HIGH TO ONLY A 40-YEAR
HIGH.
GREAT JOB.
NOW, OF COURSE BIDEN WASN'T
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE ECONOMY
TODAY.
HE HAD MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
DO LIKE A BIG CELEBRATION
FEATURING THE PRESIDENT'S -- I
NEVER THOUGHT I'D RECORD THIS --
THE FAVORITE DRAG QUEENS AND A
PERFORMANCE BY CINDI LAUPER.
FIRST, OUR ATTENTION TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TONIGHT.
CAN SOMEONE MAYBE PRETTY PLEASE
WITH SUGAR ON TOP LET THE WHITE
HOUSE KNOW THAT A MONUMENTAL
CATASTROPHE IS UNFOLDING?
IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS
OF EPIC PROPORTIONS FOR TWO
STRAIGHT YEARS NOW UNDER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS HAS NOW REACHED AN
ALL-TIME RECORD HIGH ON TOP OF
LAST YEAR'S RECORD HIGH.
THIS YEAR ARRESTS ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HAVE TOPPED OVER
TWO MILLION FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER.
IT'S ABOUT TO GET DRAMATICALLY
WORSE.
NEXT WEEK ON DECEMBER 21, TITLE
42 WILL COME TO AN END.
NOW THAT'S THE MEASURE ENACTED
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT ENABLES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
QUICKLY EXPEL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS.
SOON THE PROCESS OF DEPORTING
THOSE THAT BREAK OUR LAWS DON'T
RESPECT OUR BORDERS OR
SOVEREIGNTY WILL BE LONG, IT
WILL BE COMPLEX AND IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE IN A MATTER OF DAYS,
BY THE WAY, NOT ONLY WILL OUR
BORDER CONTINUE TO BE WIDE OPEN
BUT THE GOVERNMENT WILL BE
UNABLE TO DEPORT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN A TIMELY MANNER,
NOT THAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING THAT
ANYWAY.
NATURALLY MANY ARE WORRIED THIS
WILL CAUSE A MIGRANT SURGE
UNLIKE ANYTHING WE'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
IN TWO YEARS SINCE JOE BIDEN HAS
BECOME PRESIDENT, WE WILL HAVE
ALLOWED A WHOPPING FOUR TO FIVE
MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN TO
THIS COUNTRY, ZERO VETTING AT
ALL WHATSOEVER AND EVEN THIS
YEAR WITH THE LITTLE VETTING
THAT WE DO DO, WE FOUND 100
PEOPLE ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST.
YESTERDAY EVEN FAR LEFT GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOME TROTTED DOWN TO
THE BORDER AND DECLARE AMERICA'S
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS ABOUT TO
COLLAPSE.
INTERESTING.
HE'S COMPLAINING THAT STATE --
HIS STATE FACILITIES ARE AT
CAPACITY AND SAID THE FACT IS,
WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS NOT
WORKING.
IT'S ABOUT THE BREAK IN A POST
42 WORLD UNLESS WE TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY AND SOME
OWNERSHIP.
WELL, I THINK IT'S WAY PAST TIME
FOR YOU TO TAKE OWNERSHIP,
GAVIN.
MR. PRESIDENTIAL WANT-TO-BE,
MR. SANCTUARY CITY.
LOOK AT THIS REPORT.
IT'S ENTITLED DANGEROUS
CALIFORNIA POLICY LEAVES THREE
VICTIMS IN WAKE OF FATAL
SHOOTING.
TAKE A LOOK, GAVIN.
YOUR OWN NEWSPAPER.
IN THIS CASE, A REPEAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT WAS SHIELDED FROM
DEPORTATION BY THE LAPD AND
WENTZ ON TO MURDER A WOMAN IN
THE PRESENCE OF HER 3-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS OTHER CASES
JUST LIKE THIS JUST ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YET GAVIN NEWSOME HAS NEVER
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT HIS STATE'S
SANCTUARY POLICIES BECAUSE GAVIN
LOVES HIS STATE AND 11 MAJOR
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THE MESSAGE THAT THEY'RE SENDING
TO IMMIGRANTS AND FELLOW
DEMOCRATS, COME TO CALIFORNIA.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE DEPORTED
FOR ANY REASON AL ALL.
CALIFORNIA HANDS OUT CASH TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN ADDITION
TO PAYING THEIR HEALTHCARE AND
IN ADDITION TO PAYING THEIR
HOUSING.
IT'S NO WONDER ILLEGALS ARE
FLOCKING ACROSS THE BORDER AND
THEY'RE GOING TO CALIFORNIA IN
DROVES.
IF YOU'RE AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT,
MY ADVICE IS GO STRAIGHT TO
CALIFORNIA.
YOU'LL HAVE EVERYTHING PAID FOR
COURTESY OF GAVIN NEWSOME.
EVERY WEEK, THE CROSSINGS ARE
JAMMING OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
AND PREVENTING ICE FROM
CAPTURING CRIMINALS, DRUG
DEALERS, PEOPLE BRINGING HEROIN,
FENTANYL, NOW POURING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY UNDETECTED.
TONIGHT ONE OF BIDEN'S ONLY
COUNTER MEASURES TO THE BORDER
CRISIS IS CREATING ANOTHER
CRISIS IN THE PROCESS.
APPARENTLY JOE IS PLANNING TO
TAKE SCORES OF U.S. AIR
MARSHALLS OUT OF THE SKY, SENT
THEM TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER TO
HELP PROCESS ALL OF THIS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTSES COMING IN.
THAT PLAN WOULD STRIP 99% OF
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS FROM HAVING
ANY FEDERAL PROTECTION.
NO MORE AIR MARSHALLS WHEN
YOU'RE FLYING SO BIDEN IS
PLANNING TO SACRIFICE YOUR
SAFETY IN THE SKY AND FOR WHAT?
A COUPLE OF THOUSAND U.S. AIR
MARSHALLS THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
BE PREVENTING TWO MILLION
ILLEGALS THAT HE'S ALLOWING IN
THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO SECURE
THE BORDER?
HOW MANY MORE DRUGS WILL POUR
ACROSS THE BORDER?
HOW MANY PEOPLE WILL DIE FROM
DRUG OVERDOSES IN HOW MUCH MORE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS TOO MUCH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING FOR THE BIDE